from TMZ Target Pride controversy bomb
threat from Angry lgbtq Ally deemed a
hoax
so uh this involves us
and it happened on Friday I get a text
message asking me if it was true
and sure enough there's an email
the email says that Target is full of
swear word cowards who turned their back
on the LGBT community community and
decided to cater to the homophobic
right-wing redneck bigots blah blah blah
blah blah then says they're going to
Target a bunch of locations the email is
is listed as being sent to members at
timcast.com
we never received this email Cleveland
19 News published it we never received
that email
so I don't know where they got it from
I wonder if someone sent them a
screenshot and they like morons just
publish it yeah this is what I wanted to
ask you about because you were talking
about this over the weekend and you said
that you got a similar email but not the
same one so I'm curious why would they
make something similar and not sure the
actual one how could they have gotten
access to it no idea they could have
spoofed our email
send an email to cleveland19 but spoofed
it so that it appeared like it was sent
to us and not them but they receive it
but that just goes to show how stupid
these people are by publishing an email
that wasn't sent to them but was sent to
a different address
yeah unless the email was under the most
fake or Cleveland 19 actually staged The
hoax themselves
my guess is that somebody made it I mean
hey that's big news then it forces us
one of the biggest shows on live
streaming on YouTube to talk about it
well the great thing is if you're a
liberal and something it supports your
perspective you can say oh hey here's a
screenshot of an email I promise it's
really really true and send it to the
media and they'll publish it that's nuts
it's wild assume it's yeah this is the
article from Cleveland 19 news they say
Cleveland 19 News receives bomb threat
against five targets and store faces
lgbtq controversy but for some reason
they published an email that supposedly
was sent to us which we never received
so what like just photoshopped someone
photoshopped on the email address I'd
like to know what made this news
organization think it was good
journalism to publish an email that
wasn't sent to them without confirming
with us if we received it when we didn't
that's a very fair point they were just
like hey someone claims Tim pool Tim
pool's company received its email
running full
wait so do you know who reached out to
them what did they claim like a source
from nobody pools they just published it
no one from here
communicated with them and we did not
receive that email
I got a text from someone else saying is
this email real I saw it I said what
that what is this we immediately checked
this email does not exist we've never
gotten it no idea what this is
so what happens did someone email like
how is it that that Cleveland 19
received an email
uh and by the way I know we're we're
getting into the weeds but several
stores were were evacuated over this
oh so this was part of that they
immediately call the police for several
evacuations
do we have a lawsuit against them for
publishing this you know what happens in
the future now the person that's just
the kind of read the news a little bit
every now and then on a few websites
sees this and says all that Tim cast oh
that it's Fringe group of people that
was encouraging this awful you know bomb
scare at a Target and that's that's
what's forever in their head I think if
they don't no it looks like we are the
ones who reported it
it looks like we received it and alerted
the news in law enforcement
well I guess yeah you have to make a lot
of assumptions to get there I guess with
them the only assumptions you can make
here is that we received this and
forwarded it to the press and law
enforcement or to law enforcement who
gave it to the press or something like
that the email came from it alleged the
image says two members at timcast.com we
never got this the email does not exist
I don't know what this is or how they
got it so it looks fake and they ran it
the Assumption from any regular person
is going to be that we are the ones who
received it first and passed it on
that is very it's very strange very very
weird is this from the uh perspective of
the risk person who received the email
or from the person that sent it looking
at a draft or received it's a complete
email that says uh from N2
so I'm curious
why didn't this company reach out to us
I mean maybe I don't know maybe they
tried and nobody answered them it was
Memorial Day weekend maybe that was the
point why would they run this story
without confirming with us first how
they received an email that was sent to
us but went to them instead yeah unless
someone sent them a picture of an email
saying hey look at this thing
doesn't exist
yeah I'm just I mean it's it's hard to
even figure out what their angle would
be for doing something like this
I don't know it's weird at first I
tweeted that I thought it was a hoax and
had to smear the left and the purpose of
putting our name on it was to force us
to talk about it in the show which
they've successfully done
now I think honestly
it's a possibility but the simple
solution is just the left uses violence
and threats to gain political power
by maximizing PR reach they make sure
everybody knows they will come after
that that's it interesting
that you know you like there's no reason
to smear the left by faking something
like this with a false flag because the
left literally goes on firebombs
buildings so to be clear you're saying
you do think that this is a hoax this
particular story I'm saying that I
believe the email was actually sent by a
leftist okay intending to threaten these
establishments not that they actually
it's a bomb threat hoax because they
didn't plant any bombs but the real
purpose was psychological Terror from
someone who is likely on the left trying
to threaten people and say these are the
things that that they do has Target
issued any kind of statement about this
not that I'm aware yeah I know that it
was being claimed I mentioned earlier
that people who are boycotting Target
are extremists and haven't heard too
much from the left about this yeah what
a mess this email is any reporter that
had done even a moment of thinking I
would think would be like this email was
written to someone at a Target because
it's talking about your targets doing
this to your targets except the the the
two email addresses we are sending you a
message
see that's the other thing about it it
was sent to members that allegedly sent
to members of Tim guest.com saying they
were sending us a message threatening us
below the addresses we will continue to
the email says wow yeah well just your
teamwork is what are they talking about
like they're sending it to a Target
administrator if they're saying your
targets they're talking about but it's
the email address is not a Target email
address so pretty much some left just
drank too much Bud Light one night rode
this email
sent it off and it got reported as real
no it's more sophisticated than that
because they would have had to have
spoofed our email and then dropped the
email so they would have had to have
used some kind of spoofing so that it
went to Cleveland 19 but used our email
address instead which is not a simple
feat it's not the most complicated feat
but the average person's not gonna be
able to do it you're not you're not some
random left to slam into Bud Light and
then doing this you're you're some
hacker someone with a general knowledge
on how to spoof email addresses or BCC
because I think the BCC the blind did
not receive the email meaning it never
went to us which means it was a spoof so
it could have unless unless Cleveland 19
themselves made the fake email
intentionally to get news for this well
also we just have a screenshot here
right yeah it's extremely easy to just
inspect element in your browser type in
a fake email address under from so they
wouldn't even have to be able to spoof
an email address right honestly I won't
be surprised if somebody who worked at
Cleveland 19 fabricated the email
this is what they published the quality
super low you can see like the little
outlines inside those it's look that's
like what uh shame is saying it could be
done very easily very within the browser
just inspect edit text and then it just
it looks so bad you can just tell it
doesn't look like it's
yeah I don't know seems fake yeah yeah I
mean I have no idea who faked it or why
like I said it's a very strange thing
I'm trying to figure out the motivation
but I mean I think Tim's right I think
they're just trying to make it seem that
like we will come after you we will make
this a thing we again they like
literally too much saying a second ago
might is right to them they believe that
the power is is everything so having the
power to then show we will use this
power is everything
confusion man here's the other thing I
tweeted that this email is not real on I
think the 27th and they've not done
anything they don't like CBS 19 or
Cleveland who's the name yeah and other
people were like sharing the link being
like yo Tim pools like they don't have
this email it's not a real email and
they don't care that's why I'm like I
think maybe they did it right yeah as
Credence or maybe there's a leftist who
works there who fabricated the email put
our name on it to generate a bunch of
attention knowing that it'll spark
controversy yeah yeah it could be a two
there you go I don't know man but they
ended up evacuating a a bunch of
different Target shops all those Ohio
stores that they were listed on there no
these are Utah
which is yeah very far away which is
really odd
it's very weird yeah how far away is
that Ohio place that's like we're a
couple hours away Ohio's about five and
a half hour drive from here yeah those
are those locations all right oh those
locations yeah they can't that's like
where the college is pretty far away
yeah Utah Utah is even further it's like
at least right 22 hours drive so so the
emails that we got were different
kind of like the idea was similar and it
listed the name of other prominent
culture War individuals and so I'm like
like the the email thread was sent to
various people and I'm like okay this is
weird but I I think it's it's a spoof
it's not real
yeah someone if there's some there's
some degree of sophistication the
question is who did it was it a leftist
actually targeting these doors that's
Pro Occam's razor suggests was it but
then here's the question right because
you mentioned you did get an email that
was similar but not the same as this one
so how could the news network have
spoofed it if they had no idea that you
got a similar email like that's what's
weird about it to me is you did get a
similar email that they're the ones who
did it I don't know oh they're the ones
who sent you the initial email but then
wanted to show the actual email I have
no idea
muddling they're they're muddling people
have muddled the conversation rather
than building another beer brand we're
talking about what confused us yesterday
that's fair point dude that's a war like
that you want people turning in circles
someone in chat said Jesse Smollett yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time